je vous le disais dans le titre la météo
de ce mois d'avril est décidément pleine
de surprises mais pas forcément des
bonnes
après le gel c'est le manque d'eau qui
inquiète aujourd'hui les agriculteurs
alors que nous sommes encore à deux mois
de l'été le niveau des fleuves et des
rivières est déjà bien bas et les
professionnels de la terre scrutent le
ciel en espérant que vienne la pluie
florent clavel viala vient ses moutons
pourront-ils continuer à brouter dans
ses champs
cette agricultrice et avec son mari à la
tête d'une ferme de 600 bêtes et elle
est inquiète sur ses pâtures du nord
touraine il n'est pas tombé une goutte
d'eau depuis plusieurs semaines une
sécheresse printanière inhabituel qui
freine la repousse de l'herbe qui sert à
nourrir ses ovins au printemps
normalement c'est là où l'herbe est la
plus abondante donc au printemps on
arrive à nourrir nos animaux et à faire
du stock donc aujourd'hui en fait on va
être limite pour nourrir nos animaux et
on ne fait aucun stock on n'annonce pas
d'eau dans l'est dans les 15 prochains
jours donc
non on n'est pas très on n'est pas
optimiste du tout après le gel c'est
donc un nouveau coup dur pour
l'agricultrice et ses observations de
terrain se confirme chez météo france
avec 30 mm de pluie les deux derniers
mois ont été les plus sec depuis
soixante ans quatre fois moins d'eau que
la normale et pluies du mois de février
ont pas du tout été également répartis
dans le dans le mois parce qu elles se
sont toutes concentrées entre le 1er et
le 15 et qu'à partir du 15 il n'a
quasiment plus du tout donc on arrive à
des cumuls qui sont très faibles
des sécheresses qui se répètent assez de
si précoce s'ajoutent les sécheresses
estivales pour les agriculteurs
confrontés au phénomène
l'irrigation déjà en place n'est pas
suffisante
l'autre solution et des réservoirs de
stockage des eaux notamment des eaux de
pluie mais ces installations sont vus
d'un mauvais oeil par les écologistes et
sont encore très cher pourtant selon eux
elle permettrait de pallier le manque
d'eau sur le département il ya quelques
réservoir d'eau qui ont été mis en place
il ya 20 ans 30 ans ou ou plus et ses
réserves permettent de constituer pas du
stockage pour répondre aux besoins sur
les périodes les plus cruciales qui sont
en juillet et autres comme l'était
scrutées par les agriculteurs
le temps des moissons pour juger si les
grandes cultures blé orge colza ont
elles aussi été touchés par la
sécheresse